September 22nd three years ago my future
is in LA at BuzzFeed I honestly feel my
future there that's where I fit
professionally like my skills and
interests and personality I'm dedicating
my time and thought to being there I
[Music]
started here BuzzFeed very interesting
me before I was working here I was a
morning show reporter I actually went to
culinary school and while I was in
college I made dumb little like food
YouTube videos and as I started to kind
of play with that I really started to
enjoy the process of editing and filming
so I started as a small youtuber I used
to make cosplay videos anime videos and
actually two years ago I applied to
BuzzFeed but I didn't get it
I moved to Montana to do the news which
is what I sort of thought I wanted to do
but I was really unhappy there I hated
doing the news I hated the cold I was
always alone I had just lost my job I
got fired to be more precise I was at
Sephora working and what I really loved
to do was I'm helping people find
confidence in themselves no matter what
so I was doing my little makeup at
Sephora and then I started seeing a few
videos on like body-positive stuff
coming from this BuzzFeed thing I was
like what the [ __ ] is that and I
remember when I was still in Montana
wishing I could move back to LA but
wasn't sure what I wanted to do so
eventually I realized I want to make
videos that make people kind of forget
what they're going through a friend of
mine that was working here gave me the
suggestion to start writing just on
buzzfeed.com he was like you want to
work at BuzzFeed they hire people from
the post that you know anybody posts
there was a point in my life where it
was really hard to find a job I would
apply to all these places and for some
reason I would never get hired and I
wondered like if there was something
wrong with me like if I might not doing
it right I looked into it and I applied
for a position
and that I wasn't even qualified for I
was staying up and watching a lot of
late-night TV and I watched this episode
of the Jimmy Fallon show with Christina
Aguilera I was watching and she did this
impersonation of Britney Spears so I
quickly was like oh [ __ ]
let me write this article real quick
bird and next thing I know like it was
on the home page the next day and it got
a million views two weeks later I got an
audition and the audition was sure
enough here for BuzzFeed and I didn't
get it but the person signing me in at
the desk asked me my name and he's like
wow there's something about you you have
a look you have like the sound so I give
him my headshot he tells me that I
should meet someone so right after my
audition he introduces me to the team
need for federal like I was writing a
lot of these and a lot of my posts were
getting like a million hits before I was
even here
two years passed and I remembered
BuzzFeed again and I just had this
random thought like Oh BuzzFeed that was
something I really wanted to do might as
well try it and then within two weeks I
heard back and they were really
interested in all the cooking
competitions I had done my professional
experience and restaurants a few weeks
later they call me in from my head shop
to film a video and I did an amazing job
I guess cuz they called me again and
then they called me again and they
called me again I was going into an
interview actually that morning and I
get a phone call from this number and I
answer my phone at that point now I
don't answer any phone calls but if it's
a three mono number I'm answering
because I have a job it turns out they
took me for an interview to be a fellow
witch here that means that you have to
have actual like technical skills and I
had zero technical skills so I came in
for an interview with Eugene of all
people I was just like yeah I love
fashion look at me I'm fashionable I
love fashion and then they're like what
about your technical skills and I was
like technically I love fashion and then
I just moved on sedated from HR
on the other line and he was like well
is this Nikki Lurie and I'm like yes
this is Nick and then he was just like
so we saw your community posts and macey
who runs the curation team would love to
have you in for an interview are you
available to come in this afternoon
I said yes so fast before in my life I
was like absolutely yes and that was
after I was graduated I got a call about
like two or three days later and they
offered me the job officially they gave
me a shot and three months in after that
they offered me a busty producer oh it
was really funny coming across that
journal entry because that's exactly
what I did I moved home with the intent
of working at BuzzFeed I interviewed I
didn't get it and I was devastated but I
knew that it was just a matter of time
and so I applied again and I interviewed
again and I got it the day that I got
the phone call from BuzzFeed telling me
that I was hired was the most amazing
feeling that I've ever had that day I
remember checking my bank account and I
only had like six dollars in my account
and it didn't matter because I was just
so happy I didn't book the job that I
initially came to audition for I don't
remember what it even was but I ended up
where I needed to be regardless of
whatever roadblocks lying your way if
you feel in your heart that you belong
somewhere you belong doing something
then keep tracing it you should keep
fighting forward keep doing the things
you love whether you want to be a doctor
whether you want to be a lawyer and ask
me anything you want to do you can do
you are the god of your own universe and
you can create the path that you want to
be on so put your mind to it and you can
do whatever you wonder trust me because
it works for me
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]